version two of the paypal api was
released earlier this year and it makes
the extremely easy to start accepting
payments from your progressive web app
it's so easy in fact that I can show you
how to integrate it into angular react
and view in a single video dollar dollar
bill y'all in today's video you'll learn
the basics of the paypal version two API
and how to start accepting and capturing
real payments from your front-end
JavaScript app and it's a lot easier
than you might think if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can find the
full source code on fire ship io now
just a few days ago I implemented
PayPal payments on fire ship and also
added the ability to purchase individual
courses so ironically you can now use
PayPal to pay for my strength payments
course if you want now during this
integration I learned that PayPal 2.0
delivers a really nice developer
experience they've completely revamped
the documentation and the API in a way
that resembles stripe payments now in my
case I already have stripe implemented
so I'm using PayPal alongside it as an
additional option but you can actually
use PayPal as a standalone payment
solution to accept credit cards venmo
crypto and more well we'll be looking at
today as PayPal checkout which allows
you to mount this payment button
directly in your application and it will
take care of collecting payment details
from the user and can also capture and
charge the payment entirely from the
front end the first thing you'll need to
get started is a PayPal business account
from there you can go to the PayPal
developers dashboard and the first thing
you'll want to do is create an
application when you create this
application it will give you two sets of
API keys these sandbox keys are used to
make mock payments and to test your
integration and live keys are used for
actual payments in your production app
now each of these environments contains
two API keys the client ID and the
secret the client ID is perfectly safe
to expose in your front-end application
and we'll use that client ID in the
angular react and view apps the secret
on the other hand should never be
exposed in your front-end code or a
public github repo a secret is used to
identify your app to a back-end server
like node or firebase cloud functions so
you can use it to interact with the API
from the backend but we actually don't
even need to use it in this demo and
that's because you can use PayPal
checkout to do everything entirely from
the front-end and we'll talk a little
bit more about the trade-offs later in
the video
now we're going to implement the same
basic payment spec in angular reactant
view and even though each app is solving
the same exact problem the
implementation details vary widely let's
go ahead and get started with my
personal favorite and generate a new
angular app with the CLI the first thing
we'll do is go into the
XHTML file and include the script tag
for paypal Jas when you include the
script tag you'll also need to pass in
your client ID and you want to stick to
the sandbox client ID for now and again
you can retrieve that from the PayPal
developer dashboard now a quick side
note you might be wondering why we're
using a script tag and not installing an
NPM module the reason payment systems
generally use script tags is because
they want your site to always have the
latest version of the SDK a security
flaw on a payment system is a very big
deal so they want to make sure that
you're not running outdated code the
next thing I'll do is generate a
component then in the top of that
component
I'll declare a variable for PayPal that
PayPal script creates a global variable
called PayPal that lives on the window
object and that's how we make it known
to typescript the first thing that
PayPal needs to do is Mount the actual
button to the Dom so we need to grab an
HTML element that PayPal can attach
itself to in angular we can do that with
the view child decorator and then pass
in the name of the template reference
variable and we can make that reference
in the HTML with a hash tag now in these
examples we're just going to hard code
the product data directly into the
components but in real life you'll most
likely be pulling this information from
an API or a database somewhere in this
example here we just need some data for
the product and then we'll set a boolean
that will tell us whether or not that
products been paid for when the
component is initialized is when we'll
mount the PayPal button to the Dom
element so we call PayPal buttons and
then pass in the native Dom element to
the render method we can pass an object
to buttons
that contains the callbacks used to
handle different events that happen in
the payment lifecycle the first thing
that happens in the lifecycle is the
user clicks on the PayPal button and we
need to configure the order details to
send a paypal so they can process the
payment so we call actions or to create
and we can pass in a bunch of custom
options here but at the bare minimum
you'll want to have at least one
purchase unit and that should at least
contain a description and an amount with
a currency code this will send the user
over to PayPal where they can authorize
the order they can check out as a guest
with their credit card details or they
can use their PayPal balance or some
other form of payment on their account
at this point the order is authorized
and approved but the actual funds have
not been captured yet or in other words
the credit card has not been charged for
most simple use cases you can simply
capture the payment directly in your
front-end code by calling actions order
capture now it's important to point out
that you don't actually need to capture
the funds here if you don't want to an
alternative would be to send the data
from the
call back to your back-end server and
then process the charge there and that
tends to be a better option for more
advanced use cases where you might need
to validate the payment and then do
additional backend work after the
payment has been captured we're just
going to stick with the EZ wrap here and
capture the payment directly an angular
and then we'll set the paid for property
to true and that's something that you
would obviously want to persist in a
back-end as well in a real application
and the last thing I'll point out is
that there are additional callbacks we
can use here as well for example if we
want to catch errors we can use on error
to do that that takes care of our
typescript code now we can go over to
the HTML and set up our template logic
we'll use ng if to see if the item has
not been paid for and if not we'll go
ahead and show the price and product
details as well as the PayPal button and
if it has been paid for then we'll just
go ahead and show an order confirmation
and just like that we now have a full
stack payment solution in angular now
one thing I really like about PayPal is
that you can set up multiple mock
accounts and then you could add funds to
those mock accounts as well as credit
cards and bank accounts and things like
that so it makes it really easy to test
your implementation details in the
sandbox and that also makes it easy to
perform negative testing where you
handle different error conditions in our
demo here you can see we have a
successful mock payment and then at
console logs the payment details to the
browser and you can send this data to
your back-end to record in a database or
send a user a confirmation email and
stuff like that that takes care of our
angular integration now let's move on to
react I'll use create react app to
generate a new application and we'll
want to build this app the modern way so
we'll go ahead and import some hooks
like you state use ref and use a fact
now including a script tag and react
isn't quite as easy as it is an angular
and we need to manually create the
script and then append it to the Dom so
we have two different pieces of state
the first one paid for will tell us
whether or not the product has been paid
for and then we'll have a loaded State
that will tell us when the actual paypal
script has been loaded and if you know
of a better way to do this with react
hooks let me know in the comments then
we'll also use the use ref hooks so we
can set up a reference to a Dom element
that the actual PayPal button can be
mounted to now at this point I'm going
to jump into the JSX and build out the
template this fall is the same general
structure that we saw in angular if the
item has been paid for then we'll show
the confirmation otherwise we'll go
ahead and show the actual product
details and the payment button and to
grab an empty div from the Dom for the
button we'll go ahead and use that
reference that we defined with the use
ref hook now the next thing we need to
do is get the actual paypal J
script into our code we can do that
imperative Lee in the use effect hook
and then we'll define the script source
as the same source that we used in the
angular app but this time we want to add
an event listener to the load event and
then when it's finished loading will set
the loaded property to true on this
react component once we know that the
scripts been loaded we can then
initialize our paypal button but for
whatever reason I had to wrap this in a
set timeout because there seems to be
some weird issue between one of the
dependencies in PayPal Jas and react but
feel free to submit a pull request if
you have a good workaround for this demo
now at this point we can access PayPal
from the window object and then we'll
have the exact same code that we wrote
previously in the angular example the
only difference is that we're using
react hooks to update the state and to
grab the Dom element to mount the actual
button itself and that's all it takes to
get started with react and if you check
out the PayPal J's repo you'll see an
example for react in there as well but
it doesn't use hooks but enough of react
let's go ahead and move on to view we
can start by generating a new view app
with the view CLI and then we'll start
by defining the template because it's
conveniently located at the top of the
file the template logic is very similar
to angular because view also uses
directives so again we'll show the item
details if the item is not paid for and
then if it is paid for we'll show the
order confirmation and then we'll also
make a reference to an empty div with a
ref of PayPal the next thing we'll do is
define the data for this component which
is exactly the same as react but instead
of hooks we use a data function that
returns an object with the data that we
use in this component and view will
react automatically if we change any of
the properties on this object the next
thing we'll do is append the paypal
script to this application in the
mounted life-cycle hook this is the
exact same thing we did and they use
effect hook with react when the script
is loaded we'll have access to the
global paypal object and then we'll
mount it to that empty div that we made
a reference to earlier from there the
callbacks will be the same as the
previous examples where we first create
the order and then we capture the order
and handle any errors if necessary and
that's all it takes to implement paypal
in a view app
well that was easy yeah I guess it was
my goal with these three examples was to
show you how easy it is to start
monetizing your progressive web app but
if you want to learn more advanced
techniques consider becoming a pro
member to enroll in the stripe payments
master course you'll learn how to build
and test a reliable payment system that
can work with any front-end framework
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]